chants et danses et d'esclaves arraché
de l'afrique de l'est et de madagascar
le maloya reste l'un des piliers de la
culture musicale réunionnaise sonorités
d'abord interdite mais préservé dans des
cercles familiaux
le patrimoine a traversé les siècles
[Musique]
elle a peur
sébastien est tombé sur le maloya dans
le culte des ancêtres
aujourd'hui à la tête du groupe scolaire
mot nation il ne peut concevoir un 20
décembre à 100 maloya avant mallet a été
beaucoup ont fait aimer aujourd'hui on a
le droit du jeu donc c'est liberté pour
le marais mélange de sonorités
d'instruments traditionnels tels que le
kayamb et le sati le maloya a encore de
l'avenir
[Musique]
ras
colas redécoller normalement mais que
parce que rouler ce qu'un client ait
aucun entente rayonner sa fille était de
connaître ça senut musicanou pas
forcément ennuyeux parfois c'est manger
au moins connaître que la musique
lyonnaise les deux podiums à podium
sébastien et ses compagnons de scène
n'ont pas fini de danser le maloya en ce
jour de la fête 4 ils se produisent ce
soir à lille est quinquina à son image